so now i'm running and i had no plan and
no idea where i was heading
and my heart literally just pounding
through my chest diet to the point where
i think i'm actually gonna have a heart
attack
i just kept repeating to myself in my
head i was like i just i just can't get
caught i can't get caught
i've gone into sort of like this
undergrowth and i was getting scratched
all over my face my arms
i've come out the other side and
you know i'm in like a yard
i've seen a hole in the fence
i'm halfway through this whole i think
i'm gonna make it
and then i hear this voice stop
don't move
and at that point i knew it was over
i knew if i'd done any sort of sharp
movements and that he's probably going
to pull the trigger you know and i'd be
dead
he then kicks me
now before i know it there's like three
or four of them they're all just like
kicking me
they marched me back to the vehicle
then i've seen oh just casually chatting
to this police officer
and i was just in complete shock
he betrayed me
massively like probably the biggest
portrayal you could have in that in that
business
i was just seeing i was fuming inside
i just wanted to grab hold of him
[Music]
but the future wasn't in my hands
they give you know life sentences and
you know the death centers for drugs in
thailand
and i am like
completely honest
so after that i was taken to a safe
house
you know my mind just still going round
and round and doing somersaults
i remember thinking
i'd come to thailand you know start a
new life build the relationship back up
with my dad and here i was my dad would
find out the hard way when he word got
around about what just happened
you know i was just left handcuffed to
this bed
and i was there all night
and my body was craving ice
i was going through like cold turkey
basically
there's only one place that i'll be
going they call it a monkey house a hell
hole basically
you know they eventually put me back in
the truck
and they drove me to a prison in bangkok
i remember seeing like the wall
i just didn't know what was on the other
side that was the scary bit are they
going to sort of target me as anything
can happen to me
this could be my future for you know a
very long time
i didn't know how long
they basically said take all your
clothes off they felt awful
your self-dignity is just gone
[Applause]
they're sort of checking in my mouth
in my genital area
you just don't even feel like you're a
person anymore you know you just feel
like a bit of meat that you know you're
just being treated that way
this place was just like you know a
living hell hole and this was now my new
reality
the officer's taking me to the cell
block
i've got all these prisoners you know
i'm fellaing
which is like type as they say for
and i remember foreign over and seeing
two time mates in front of this guard
who was holding a stick the next minute
he's just smashed it down
on the fingertips of the inmate he's
going to smash smash smash
no emotion at all
at that point i thought
there's no way i want to be causing
trouble in here that's for sure
it was actually dark at that point so
it's like what now
and then uh one of the guys he was like
you he's like you sit here
it was just so crammed and like there
was just no space at all in there
i was sleeping on a hard cold floor in a
water bowl as as my pillow
it was just soul destroying
i felt really agitated i was getting the
cold sweats because my body was still
craving ice
got this guy at the same point shouting
and you know he's having some sort of
nightmare
that is the most depressed and helpless
that i've ever felt in my life to be
honest at that point
everything that i'd heard about what
these thai prisons were like it was true
and it was happening you know in front
of my eyes and
it's like your worst nightmare
[Music]
you